from pennsylvania is recognized i
reserve
okay then um i will yield one moment to
the majority leader mr hoyer
the gentleman from pennsylvania the
gentleman from maryland has recognized
the gentleman
the majority is recognized for one
minute
[Music]
madam speaker first of all i wrote rise
in strong support
of this resolution
it makes in order that we will not
discriminate against people based upon
their religion
or or the state from which they come the
nation from which they come
it says not at our cost but at their
cost they
have the right to consult
council that seems to me a basic premise
in america and then thirdly which we
hear so much lamentation about
gives to 700 000 plus people in the
district of columbia
equal status with the 500 000 people in
wyoming
how terrible
now perhaps if my friends from the other
side of the aisle madam speaker thought
that there were going to be two
republican
senators elected they'd be for it
i say perhaps but i believe there's no
doubt about that
i am proud to be a strong supporter of
that legislation
and i will tell my republican friends
who talk about human rights around the
world so often
properly so
that washington dc is the only capital
in the free world whose
residents do not have a representative
in the parliament of their country
the only one
there is no reason while the gentlelady
who sits in front of me eleanor
holmes-norton who's an extraordinary
american an extraordinary patriot
who served her nation so incredibly well
and is elected by those 700 000 people
why she
is less than we
because eleanor holmes norton cannot
vote on final passage of a bill
now i did as majority leader at least
give her the respect and respect of
others
who are representatives of their
particular areas
puerto rico american samoa guam the
northern marianas
the right to vote in the committee of
the whole
to let them know at least in that small
way we wanted to give
voice to the folks they represent
so i rise in strong support of this rule
we passed these bills before republicans
opposed them before
and they'll repose them again i'm not
surprised
madam speaker before i sit however i
want to speak about another issue
we are expecting the republican leader
to offer a privileged resolution at the
conclusion of the debate on this rule
i'm disappointed at that news his
resolution is being used by
republicans to posit a moral equivalence
between a comment by the gentlelady from
california
standing up for justice and peaceful
protest
and remarks by representative greene
who directly threatened violence by
retweeting a tweet
i understand it was not her words
but she retweeted retweeted those words
which said
that if you want to shut pelosi up a
bullet to the head will accomplish that
objective
she didn't say it i want to make that
clear she retweeted
a tweet that said that
even more egregiously it is being used
to twist reality to success that
somehow congresswoman walter's remark
is a condemnation it's a command
condemnable remark
as rhetoric that incites a violent
attempt to overthrow the government of
the united states
on january 6. an action
that republicans refuse to condemn
no it will not there is no
equivalence chairwoman walters remarks
reflect the very profound anger
and sense of hopelessness that she
and so many others myself included
feel when we see african-americans being
killed
during encounters with our law
enforcement
and their families not seeing justice
it's my understanding we're going to get
a ruling almost perhaps
any minute we will see
it is however irresponsible to take
chair waters remarks out of conduct
context to just hold a gotcha partisan
vote
particularly
when no action was taken by their party
by her party
regarding miss green's remarks it is
frankly exploiting the pain of so many
families and communities to turn
chairwoman waters
concerned for justice into a partisan
cudgel
say some group's
biggest fear
confront is not to say be violent
in confronting the facts and the truth
and the opportunities and the challenges
and yes the alternatives that we'll take
and so if one of us
stands up and said we need to confront
this
and we need to be confrontational we
need to get up in pieces
people's face and say this is the truth
and we need to act
and that would be subject
to admonition then i suggest to my
friend
madam speaker and my friends in this
house
that we all confront we came here
to represent people and to confront
their needs
to confront their fears
to confront their wants
now yes you could say well that's
advocacy of course it is
so i ask my friends not only to vote for
this rule
but to vote for the motion to table of
my friends uh
motion that i anticipate
we could spend all our time here madam
spear we've been um
on this side of the aisle as my friend
the leader knows
we haven't had all the resolutions that
have been introduced on my side of the
aisle
this makes it harder however not to
proceed on
numerous resolutions on my side of the
aisle
let us table this resolution
on behalf of this institution and every
member in it
i yield back the balance of my time
the gentleman from maryland reserves
reserve
the gentleman from pennsylvania is
recognized thank you madam speaker i
would just like to confirm
that my colleague across the aisle has
no further speakers
but we have no further speakers and
we're prepared to close and i would
reserve
general from pennsylvania thank you
madam speaker i'm prepared
to close uh and i deal with myself as
much time as i may consume
the gentleman is recognized thank you
madam speaker it's interesting to hear
my colleague from maryland's uh newfound
positions
because in the 90s i believe the
majority leader actually had
the opposite viewpoint and took the
opposite vote
but then again things can change and so
can opinions
it's also interesting to hear my
colleagues on the other side of
use dc's population as some
justification
for dc statehood we know that the
founding fathers
knew that dc would grow into a large
metropolis
george washington when he was laying out
this city
when he was laying out the the land use
of the city
actually used paris as the example for
this city
which was at the time 800 000 residents
they used one of the biggest cities in
europe
as an example for this city because they
knew that the district of columbia
would grow into a thriving metropolis
yet they still
wanted to carve out dc as an independent
district
not as a state the argument that there
are now 700
some residents of dc is a non-starter if
you're going back to the
historical intent of the founding
fathers
but let's talk about the border crisis
there has been a
400 increase in illegal border crossings
compared to march 2020 400 percent
yet today we're considering a role
bringing up two immigration bills that
do absolutely nothing to address this
crisis
and again we're calling up a rule hr on
h.r 51
that is the democrats attempt an
unconstitutional attempt
to ram through dc statehood for their
own political gain
and what is that gain it's very simple
it's bringing in two
ultra liberal senators dc is the most
liberal city second only to san
francisco
bringing in two ultra-liberal senators
into
the senate with the idea of abolishing
the filibuster
and to what end to pack the supreme
court to ram through a far-left
radical agenda for those reasons
madam speaker i urge my colleagues to
vote no on the previous question
and no on the underlying measure thank
you i yield back my time
the gentleman yields back the gentleman
from maryland is recognized
thank you madam speaker um
let me start with this uh the majority
leader hardly needs me to defend him but
i know that he was a strong supporter of
the d.c voting rights constitutional
amendment
where there was actually bipartisan
support in those days republicans
understood the grievous injustice being
perpetrated against people in washington
dc
and they supported granting people in dc
two senators or what my colleague would
call
two ultra liberal senators as well as
the representatives in the house to
which they were due
so there were certainly people who were
saying there were other ways of
accomplishing it
now unfortunately that bipartisan
uh consensus collapsed even though it it
passed the
the senate in the house back in the day
i don't hear any of my colleagues saying
they're foreign
viable vehicle for getting equal rights
for people in washington dc that exists
today
which is statehood which is how 37 new
states
uh entered the union with congress's
exercise of its powers under article 4
of the constitution the gentleman
waxes eloquent about the vision of a
great capital city
but being a strict textualist
i assume that he wants to pay some
attention to the text of the
constitution
article section 8 clause 17 the district
clause sets a maximum
a ceiling that the district may be no
more than 10 miles square
but there's no minimum there it didn't
say it must be at least
six miles square or two miles square or
three miles no
that's up to congress in other words
it's a political question
within congressional power our plenary
power over
the district of columbia now finally
the gentleman i suppose gets to the
heart of the matter
when he says that for him it's all about
two
ultra liberal senators and i would ask
every member of this body to think about
that for a second reflect about that
because in america i don't think we deny
people voting rights
based on how they're going to vote i
don't think we deny entire states and
political communities
representation based on predictions of
who they might elect in fact there's a
supreme court case about that
called carrington versus rash when armed
service members in texas
were disenfranchised because it was
suggested that they would vote in a way
uh more identified with the national
government than with
local cultural values in texas because
we technically
will still be waiting for the outcome at
this point
the only thing is if you have
and with local cultural values in texas
still hold because we technically will
still be waiting
for the outcome at this point
the only thing is